As the founder of Playboy
magazine who half?
No,
it was one of the icons of the
sexual revolution in the 1960s.
Opinions about half
now are very polarized,
either love and admire the man
who you completely disapprove of,
the multimillion dollar
empire that he created.
But no matter how you
feel about Hugh Hefner,
there is no arguing that he was truly
a genius when it came to business.
And,
uh,
one of the kinds publisher,
writer and is on trapping now,
Hugh Austin half note was
born in Chicago in 1926.
He grew up in the middle of prohibition
on his parents were conservative
Methodists.
His mother was a teacher and his father
was an accountant during the Great
Depression.
His father was under a lot of pressure
to work as hard as he possibly could in
order to keep his job.
He would leave the house before Hugh
and his brother key if even woke up for
school and he works late into the night.
He was a very timid and shy Ellis or
why he preferred to read comic books and
watch movies.
Most of the Hollywood starlets in the
1920s and thirties just happened to be
buxom blonde girls with
an hourglass figure,
and so you grew up escaping into a
fantasy world of romance and adventure,
wishing that he could
live inside these movies.
In elementary school you did not talk
very much and he didn't seem to be paying
attention to class.
He spent most of his time drawing in his
notebooks with his mind ends up in the
clouds.
It was unresponsive to his
just questions as well,
so they thought that he might have
some sort of a learning disability.
His mother took him to a
child psychologist and it
turns out that he had an Iq
of 152 which makes them a genius.
The reality was that he was simply bored
with what he was learning in class.
When he started going to high school,
he had his heartbroken when a girl he had
a crush on started dating another boy,
and at this point he was still shy,
ended trouble communicating,
but the perceived rejection from
this gal was a wake up call.
From that moment on,
he realized that he needed to reinvent
himself if he ever wanted to get a
girlfriend.
He asked his friends to start
calling him half instead of humans.
He began to wear nicer clothes,
Cologne and stylists hat underneath
all of these outward improvements.
However,
he was still that hardcore film that he
wrote plays for the theater department
and he films his own horror movies with
a home video camera with his friends.
He worked on the school newspaper and
drew comic books in his spare time.
When he was 15 he created his own xen,
but he had fully illustrated
and he calls it shutter.
Yeah.
He wrote articles about horror movies.
He mess up with a group of friends after
school calls the shutter club where
they got together to watch
films and talk about them.
It was at this point that he finally
came out of his shell and he was popular
enough to be elected student body
president from 1944 to 1946 you have not
served in the U s army.
He used his talents in writing
to work in the military.
His newspaper,
since he did not have a combat position,
be lived out the adventures in his mind
by drawing comic books about fantasy
versions like one way here in a of his
friends were breaking prisoners out of a
Nazi concentration camp during World War
Two illustrations and photos of pinup
girls were extremely popular in order
to boost soldiers' morale that were even
paintings of Miss America
on the sides of airplanes,
bombers instead of staring at
scantily clad strangers in his bunk,
you have now gazed at photos
and letters from his fiance,
Miljard Williams.
He was very much in love with her and
the plans again married when the war was
over.
After being discharged from the army,
you have no end to the University of
Illinois and double majored in psychology
and creative writing.
He excelled in school and he was able to
earn his bachelor's degree in just two
and a half years.
He also wrote for the College
newspaper and magazine.
He was eager to marry
Mildred after graduation,
but the idea that he was getting to
live out the plot of a Hollywood romance
when it came crashing
down before the wedding,
Mildred confessed that she had had an
affair when he was away in the army.
He forgave her though and he lost
his virginity on his wedding night.
They went on to have
two children together,
Christine and David.
He was very much in love with Mildred
and even though it broke his heart,
he believed in the old
traditional way of doing things.
During an interview
with the New York Times,
having to explained how he
felt on his wedding day,
the magic was gone from
the very beginning.
How would it have turned out without
the affair was like well suited for
marriage.
I didn't know boss.
I was truly crushed
after serving in the army and graduating
from college who have not got a job at
Esquire magazine,
making $60 a week with
modern day inflation.
That's about $645 a week after
working there for several years.
Half of the knew that
he was good at his job,
so he asked his boss
for a $5 a week raise.
This doesn't sound like a lot to ask,
but they still said no.
At this point he was starting to
have a bit of a quarter life crisis.
I've been doing last point.
He had followed all of the rules of living
the so called American dream that he
was unhappy with his job and he
was in an unfaithful marriage.
He decided that he truly
had nothing left to lose,
so he quit his job and worked
on starting his own magazine.
You have no knew from being in the army
that men love looking at pictures of
pinup girls.
When they came home from the war,
many men did not have access to it
anymore because it was illegal to send
anything that was considered pornographic
in the mail and that's how I men's
magazines were mostly about hunting,
fishing,
camping,
and cause have not sold.
This is a golden opportunity
to start his own publication.
The only issue was that
he was completely broke.
You borrowed $1,000 from his mother,
mortgaged out his furniture to the bank
for $600 and convinced several investors
to help him raise a total of $8,000 to
get the first issue of playboy started.
At first he thought about naming
the magazine's stag party.
You just decided against it.
Since there was already
a magazine called Stag,
you have no was able to by
Marilyn Monroe's nude photos
from accounting's as a
company who owned the rights.
These photographs were famous,
but since this was decades before people
could easily share is on the Internet.
Very few people that actually seen them
for just $200 he bought the rights to
the pictures and published them in the
very first issue of playboy Zinn's.
Marilyn Monro was of the
biggest celebrities of the time.
He couldn't have picked a better
woman to place on the cover.
Magazines were flying off the
shelves and they sold 50,000 copies.
The money they made from that issue
was just enough to make the seconds and
after a few months they
were turning a profit.
It soon enough they were selling over a
million copies a month and playboy was
essentially an overnight success.
Now,
it sounds like a joke when people say
they read playboy for the articles,
but there's actually a lot
of truth to that statement.
Hugh Hefner was always against censorship
in the media andZ ran one of the very
few publications where writers get to
express themselves without holding back.
Some of the greatest authors in the world
actually got their start writing for
playboy.
Ian Fleming was one of them and he
went on to write James Bond's and ray
Bradbury serialized chapters of Fahrenheit
four five one in the magazine before
publishing the complete novel.
Even Margaret Atwood published several
short stories in playboy before writing
our feminist dystopian novel.
The Handmaid's tale in the 1950s you
have not was defying all rational
convention and actually promoted feminism
and women's sexual liberation as well
as racial equality.
In 1959 a series called playboys
penthouse ad on the television.
For the first time,
women were shown on TV as more than
just housewives who were staying home to
make a dinner and take
care of the children.
The premise of the show was that the
viewer followed around half an hour as he
had to classy party in
his penthouse apartment.
Women Wa elegant dresses and men wore
suits as they drank cocktails and had
interesting conversations while
they listen to live jazz music.
It was sophisticated and that lifestyle
became an aspiration for many men and
women who watched the series.
Now at this point,
you have to his marriage,
it was crumbling and he and his wife,
Mildred had agreed to allow one
another to sleep with different people.
They officially called it quits
in 1959 and got a divorce,
which left him free to live the bachelor
lifestyle to match the playboy brand.
That same year,
he bought his first a mansion and
opens the playboy club in Chicago.
Soon enough,
he would open dozens of clubs all over
the country so that men could experience
the playboy and penthouse
lifestyle firsthand.
By the time he turned 35 the play by
empire had expanded to a lifestyle brand
worth $20 million.
As time winds on the magazine would come
to be published in over 180 countries
and it became one of the top
20 brands in the entire world,
right wing conservatives.
They were against playboy from the very
first issue because they considered the
magazine to be sinful trash.
He also gone a lot of criticism from the
left as well because feminists saw that
it was objectifying and over sexualizing
women rather than liberating them.
After receiving so much criticism who
haven't published a book called the
playboy philosophy in 1962 where are you
explains his ideas about sex in modern
culture and attends to explain his
thought process behind you're running the
business.
In 1963 a journalist named Gloria Steinem
went undercover for showing magazines
at work as a waitress and
one of the playboy clubs.
She found out that these girls were
being underpaid and as they were charged
fees,
whenever they committed,
even the smallest infractions,
like not smiling enough,
they were also being treated
very badly by the customers.
And in the ends,
women hardly made any money in
order to be sexually objectified.
Clients were given special keys that
allowed them to have total access to the
playboy bunnies,
which needs the club.
A glorified brothel.
Steinem wrote about her experiences and
she was seen as a hero for feminism by
exposing what was going
on behind closed doors.
Now,
Hugh Hefner,
he took this criticism seriously and
responded by making sure that the women
working in his clubs,
they were being treated fairly
and being paid a proper wage.
But as they say,
even bad press is good press.
And despite all of the controversy,
the playboy brand continue to thrive
today,
it's difficult to imagine playboy and
without the mansion filled with beautiful
girls.
But you have not did not by the iconic
house in Los Angeles until 1974 the
mansion sets on five acres
and comes with a movie room,
a massive wine cellar,
a gym,
tennis courts,
and even a zoo with exotic animals.
You have not began hosting at some of
the biggest parties in history of the
playboy mansion with celebrity
guests visiting on a regular basis.
He was still the most popular guy around
even well into his old age in the year
1980 personally paid for the repair of
the iconic Hollywood sign and the city of
Los Angeles gave him a
star on the celebrity walk,
a thin as a thank you gift.
And the 1980s playboy began
to struggle as a brand.
After it became a publicly
shared cooperation,
they were competing with the
likes of Penthouse magazine.
So that peak in popularity was over.
You have now handed control of
the company over to his daughter,
Christie,
who became the new CEO,
have no tried to give normal
domestic life another chance.
And he got married to his second wife,
Kimberly Conrad.
In 1989 she gave birth to two sons,
Maston and Cuba.
Aaron's.
They got to have a fantasy childhood
growing up in the playboy mansion.
That relationship didn't last though,
and they separated in 1988 and became
officially divorced in 2010 after the
separation,
you haven't to began to invite his
girlfriend's to live in the house with him
and even experimented with bisexuality.
He had a polyamorous lifestyle where he
had multiple girlfriends at one time,
but always had a number
one girl by a site.
He knows you're admitted that he had slept
with roughly 11 out of the 12 monthly
playboy cover models in 1999 one if
you happen to his ex girlfriends,
Carrie Lee said that living in the
playboy mansion was almost like a cult
because it was so easy to get caught up
in the lifestyle and the drama with the
multiple girlfriends.
She got so caught up in the playboy
lifestyle that she forgot what was
considered normal in the outside world.
However,
unlike a real cults,
the girls living in the house were
free to come and go as they pleased.
They still have that own personal
relationships and kept in touch with their
families.
Some of them even went to college classes
full or part time and their work with
playboy helps them pay for that tuition.
In two and five the reality TV series,
girls next door premiered and it gives
people a look into the lives of the
people living and working
in the playboy mansion.
It reveals new Heffernan's new lifestyle
with a team of employees to take care
of all of his needs.
The girls he lived with were also given
an allowance to buy whatever they want
it.
Of course,
they are living in the mansion came with
the understanding that Hugh Hefner only
at wanted to be involved in an open
relationship where he could sleep with
whoever he wants it,
but the girls were not allowed
to have another friends.
Even though this may seem like
a dream scenario for some men,
the arrangement was not always a
walk in the park for half an hour.
Some of the women who once lived with
him sued him for palimony after that
breakup,
which is like Alan for people
who are living together,
but we were not married
during an interview.
One of half of his ex girlfriends,
Holly Madison,
explains that women were competing with
one another for the privilege of being
in Hugh Hefner's in a circle,
dozens of small town goals which see
their careers skyrocket after modeling in
playboy and they were desperate
to become a part of it.
Almost every girl who was involved with
the brands moved on to either having a
big modeling career or
marrying a millionaire because
I'm having sex with you
half know it was a very small price to
pay for guaranteed fame and fortune.
As he got older,
you have no new batter than to expect
any of these young women to be as true
love.
He said during an interview with
the New York Times that having seven
girlfriends was actually a much easier
lifestyle to manage than having just one
wife in 2012 he was 86 years old and
he decided that it was finally time to
settle down.
He married Crystal Harris,
who was just 26 on the reality TV show.
Girls next door.
He was girlfriends,
showed off their happy lifestyles
living in the playboy mansion,
but Holly Madison came out with a tell
all book in 2015 saying that she had
actually been manipulated into staying
with you half an hour for so many years.
She said that she was truly
in love with him at first,
but when she finally got the exclusive
relationship that she was looking for,
she was no longer in love with him.
She eventually married a millionaire
event organizer or Pascal Rotella.
You have to respond to to Madison's
accusations in her book saying it was an
attempt to do rewrite history for the
sake of staying relevant in the media and
making money on a book deal.
And 2016 it was clear that he
has in his health was declining,
so he decided to sell his mansion in Los
Angeles for $100 million to a man named
Darren Metropole.
This in 2018 which are Polis,
convinced the city of Los Angeles to add
protections to the house so that it can
never be torn down.
The playboy mansion has essentially been
turned into a historical landmark if
you have not died peacefully in September
of 2017 surrounded by his friends and
family when he was 91 years old.
Even though he never got
to meet Marilyn Monroe,
he's still accredited her
nudes for all of his success.
This is why he punches the
burial plot right next to hers.
Love him or hate him.
You have no,
it's still an icon that will be
remembered forever before he passed away.
He said this about his career.
I've never been in it for the money.
Playboy isn't a business for me.
It has been the very beginning,
a labor of love,
and that's pretty easy to say because
if you don't love all of this,
you're a fool.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe.
We have a few videos released every week,
so hit that subscribe button,
hit that Bell,
and you will find out about all of those.
Give us a like if you enjoyed it,
and as always,
thank you for watching.